[Music]
welcome to water's world i'm jesse
waters the truth about joe biden that's
the subject of tonight's waters words
i'm sick of beating around the bush time
to call a spade a spade joe biden is a
horrible president
i've seen enough
on pace to be one of the worst of all
time most of the country thinks he's
incompetent democrats don't want him to
run again everybody's disappointed we
didn't think it would be this bad this
fast everything and i mean everything he
says he's gonna do he doesn't do and
everything he says is true isn't true
this was his campaign pledge
i'm not gonna shut down the economy
i'm gonna shut down the virus
[Applause]
he didn't shut down the virus did he
still clocking in over a thousand deaths
a day more deaths under biden than trump
and it feels like the economy shut down
empty shelves high prices and canceled
flights
this summer biden said inflation was
temporary
most of the price increases we've seen
are were expected and expected to be
temporary
wrong again joe inflation's rising at
the fastest pace in 30 years and not
looking back
in august joe said he was getting a
handle on rising gas prices
we're taking action to address gas
prices as well
biden to do anything can anybody name a
thing joe biden did to try to reduce gas
prices
if he did anything it didn't work
the national average is up to nearly 350
a gallon people are getting hurt
he said he'd open ports and fix the
supply chain mess
this is across the board commitment
to going to 24 7.
so by increasing the number of late
night hours of operation and opening up
for less crowded hours when the goods
can move faster today's announcement has
the potential to be a game changer
nothing changed everything's still
jammed up cargo ships from asia still
floating not enough truckers lots of
shortages prices are rising
vax mandates aren't helping the vaccine
biden promised wouldn't be mandatory
no i don't think it should be mandatory
i wouldn't demand to be mandatory
why should we believe anything he says
at this point joe said he wasn't going
to leave any americans behind in
afghanistan remember
and if they're american forces if
there's american citizens left we're
going to stay to get them all out
wrong hundreds of americans stranded
there stranded in a foreign land on
veterans day but biden brings millions
of foreign nationals into our homeland
the steady stream of illegals flooding
in after he was inaugurated he says this
happens every year
there is a significant increase in the
number of people coming to the border in
the winter months of
january february march
that happens every year
it doesn't happen every year just every
year joe's president he smashed the
all-time illegal alien entry record
year's not even over yet
where to go joe
maybe instead of kamala biden should put
hunter in charge of the border after all
joe says he's the smartest man he knows
he is the smartest man i know i mean
afraid of pure intellectual capacity i
am not concerned about any accusations
but made against him it's used to get to
me
i think it's kind of foul play
hunter is under federal investigation
for chinese money laundering and tax
fraud and while under investigation for
money laundering it looks like hunter
biden the artist is laundering money by
selling his own paintings to anonymous
buyers
hunter's paintings price higher than
signed picassos
right
while the first families getting rich
off the taxpayer are illegal alien
families getting rich off the taxpayer
too
there were reports that were surfacing
that your administration is planning to
pay
illegal immigrants who are separated
from their families at the border up to
450 000 each possibly a million dollars
per family
do you think that that might incentivize
more people to come over illegally if
you guys keep sending that garbage out
yeah but it's not true so this is a
garbage report yeah
wrong again
biden 180 and then said yeah we're
planning on paying illegals the doj is
settling for millions but it was trump's
fault
biden said he'd never use his department
of justice for political purposes like
the way he said trump did
the justice department under my
administration
will be totally independent of me
i will not direct them who to prosecute
how to prosecute what to prosecute
and i will not be in injecting i will
not enter their decisions based upon the
judgments they make about what cases
they bring and they don't bring
biden's justice department just raided
james o'keefe's apartment over what
over biden's daughter's missing diary
that sounds very independent of the
president i'm sure the president had
nothing to do with federal agents
hunting for his daughter's lost diary
maybe if biden's children would stop
losing laptops and diaries president
biden can save his party from disaster
at the ballot box
we're going to win
i think we're going to win in
virginia not only doesn't he have the
pulse of the people
we don't even know if he has a pulse
not only did joe pass out in the uk
apparently he passed something else
in front of the royal family
it was long and loud and impossible to
ignore the source said camilla hasn't
stopped talking about it
but america never got wind of this our
media won't talk about a lot of what we
just talked about here tonight the biden
protection plan is killing the media
cnn's media show reliable sources is
being beaten by reruns of martin
not new episodes of martin
reruns
all i want to know is the wyman had a
party and didn't invite me i mean i
liked the party
the people would rather watch reruns of
martin than watch the press carry joe's
water and they better lift harder
because biden's underwater everywhere
he's at 38 approval in the latest poll
and that's with the media propping him
up imagine if they treated biden like
trump and trump had slept through and
stunk up his uk trip
then sent the feds to raid the home of a
cnn reporter because ivanka's diary was
missing oh and everybody was still dying
from covet and
don jr was under investigation for tax
fraud and gas was twice as pricey
if it were that bad for my guy
i'd be watching reruns of martin too hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else